good morning John last week I was in
Amsterdam and as usual when I go
someplace that is not my home I'm struck
by all of the little differences like
all the bikes and the trains and the
trams where in my town almost everybody
gets around by car it's easy to say that
this is a question of circumstance and
of course it is in Amsterdam it's dense
the roads are old and narrow and the
country is flat and isn't covered in
snow half the year like it is here in
Montana but it's also a question of
choice individuals making decisions in
establishing and following norms in
Amsterdam even if it's faster to take a
bus even if it's raining and gross
people still bike because that's what
you do and since so many people do
everything is built for bikes and trams
and trains while I imagine trying to
find parking would be a miserable
terrible disaster I don't actually know
though how these norms get established I
imagine that they are things that just
fit things that simply make sense to the
people who have come together to make a
place norms that make them feel good and
valued and healthy and satisfied the
blending of story into place into groups
that's the thing that I thought a lot
about this year at VidCon d-u because
it's also the story of online
communities which is what VidCon
ultimately is about
I've been gonna EU this year we weren't
able to have a fan component for a bunch
of reasons that I'll put on the screen
right now if you're curious but it was
still able to be that kind of cultural
exploration we get a chance to ask where
our ideas come from what stories we are
telling to ourselves and to each other
and whether they're good stories having
the community there I think makes that
even better which is why I came away
from VidCon you so excited for Anaheim
and Australia later this year I'm
working on what I think are some pretty
good speeches for those vidcon's about
defining success and some of the
strategies that I find really work when
trying to figure out what kind of
content is going to get attention and be
successful but also not be bad for the
people watching it I'm excited about my
panels and also to do an old-school
acoustic set to close out the whole
event in Anaheim I guess being a founder
has its advantages I'm really proud of
VidCon proud of people who take their
stories seriously and who let them
change and be
messy and complex a couple of weeks ago
on our new podcast delete this Katherine
and I were talking about how the
messiness of stories can make it hard to
love something a hundred percent but
maybe loving something 100 percent isn't
right maybe it starts with joy and ends
with joy but joy that also has care and
concern and thought mixed in and if
we're not doing it that way I don't even
know if that's right
it's why I love VidCon and also why I
love my new podcast where Katherine
perfuse my Twitter feed and if you want
to find out more about those things
there's links and maybe even some coupon
codes in the description any opportunity
to examine the stories I tell myself is
something I want more of in my life
taking an hour every week to go through
my Twitter feed with someone who cares
about me a lot is a great way to do that
and so is traveling to a new place and
making a bunch of cool time-lapse videos
and so is getting together to celebrate
and contemplate with a bunch of people
who care about and love and are excited
about and also worried about a lot of
the same things as me John I'll see you
on Tuesday
[Music]